she's a witch incredible yeah her
Bonkers Pinterest account which promotes
witchcraft promoting witchcraft does not
make you a witch practicing witchcraft
does does she practice thank you for
clearance that was a 20. that is that is
that is technically the truth thank you
very much literally the truth oh so is
this like a is this like a an ad for us
to read about how to become a witch
we're gonna learn how to become a witch
today she's totally into witchcraft oh
yeah I wanna I wanna learn one of my
ring Bowl the pentagram you know Emily
Charlie Kirk says Emily core is the four
person on the Trump grand jury in
Georgia really putting the witch in
which wow yeah we're in a simulation I'm
sorry you can't I'm sorry we're in a
simulation can you go back up to the
first picture there's you you you're not
going to convince me this is uh that all
of this is just like random chance that
Trump is like it's a Witch Hunt and then
they actually have a jury four person
who's a witches to interview and that's
who they chose to interview too